in this demonstration we show a new
haptic display that delivers touch
feedback to a finger on a touchscreen we
provide different feedback depending on
whether the fingers sliding on the
screen or clicking an object on the
screen two scenarios have been developed
in the first scenario we show a button
clicking demonstration the second demo
shows a some typing scenario the first
scenario is a simple one it focuses on
the sensations that can be delivered
with a haptic display the visual display
shows four buttons the buttons on the
Left have a rough surface texture the
buttons on the right have a smooth
surface texture the texture can be felt
by sliding a finger over the button in
addition the two buttons on the top have
a smaller travel distance than the two
buttons on the bottom when a user clicks
on the buttons the two buttons on the
bottom give a stronger key clock
sensation in the two buttons on the top
the second demo incorporates sliding and
clicking haptic feedback into a thumb
typing scenario the left thumb moves up
and down along an arc in the lower left
corner of the touchscreen this is mapped
to three letters in a vertical alphabet
display the user selects desired letter
with the right thumb three buttons can
be found at the lower right corner of
the screen clicking on the top button
selects the top letter clicking on the
middle button selects the middle one and
so forth this way the left arm does the
positioning while the right thumb does
the selection the locations of the arc
for the left phone and the three buttons
for the right thumb can be felt as a
different texture by sliding the thumbs
on the touchscreen a key click feedback
is triggered whenever the right thumb
taps on one of the three buttons the
haptic display shown in this demo
provides both sliding and clicking
feedback to enhance a user's experience
on the touchscreen by integrating the
haptic display with a Kindle Fire we
show that our new haptic display can be
used with existing mobile touchscreen
devices for improved
entry